So speaking of flying I'm going to play
a little tape tell me if this looks
familiar let's play a little tag let's
play a little tape okay does this ring a
bell oh yeah I'm telling
I'm telling you and there's a reason why
I'm getting
everyone
Believe it or they cannot believe it I
don't give two but I am telling you you
right now she almost lost her voice
back there
is she talking about you no no no no no
I was in first class could you hear this
happening I was sitting right there in
the first seat in the first class yeah
could you hear this what's funny about
it of course I could what was funny is
I'm right there what's funny about it
was when I sent when someone during the
eight hour layover because of this woman
we were all sitting in Dallas and
someone one of the people on the plane
had videotaped it so they came over and
said
um do you wanna I said what you have the
tape give me oh my God I want to like
post it and and just say you know and
but before it became this thing it
wasn't huge yeah it was just this little
thing and I I said you know I was going
to make the fireworks but I'm not gonna
now because of some I said some Nut Job
lost her mind on the plane so I'm gonna
miss the fireworks and then it became in
Beyond national news but when I sent it
to my friend the video first thing he
says is you're in coach I'm like
no I'm not in coach no no I'm not in
coach but uh that I was sitting right
yeah it was the first seat in like 4A
and she was standing right with the book
and I we were all just looking at her I
thought at first I thought it was just a
flight attendant that had gone back to
tell someone because the flight
attendant had her mic in her hand and
she was annoyed it's like everyone needs
to take her seats for an active taxiway
and so on and she puts the mic in one
that way so I figured oh someone's
standing up putting their bag in the you
know their jet ski in the overhead bin
right and um
and then finally uh this woman just
started screaming and I looked up and
like and she's just screaming I was like
oh God
and then she went off and everybody
would just look they no one said
anything and looked off and I said to
the woman next to me this is not good
and she said well she's gone I said no
we're all gonna have to get off the
plane now you know this and she's like
why I said because that was a complete
like
it's like a bomb something bomb scare
thing you know you can't say that that's
not real and then they came back where
is the woman's luggage oh it's oh it's
still on so we yeah so we had to get off
the plane no one was freaking out
people were here's what I thought and I
think most people thought I thought
there was a guy that brought her this is
true I owe this after that she was
screaming if that guy's not real I'm
thinking oh there's a guy that probably
took on a trip and wasn't really you
know didn't have the money didn't they
didn't have the sweet they didn't have
the nice cat nice restaurant some idiot
took her on some trip and [__] it all
up
I thought there was going to be some guy
walking up with his bags like sorry
about my wife or you're my girlfriend
and there was no guy so that's when I
said oh there's no she's talking about
somebody like invisible invisible person
so this is not good so then yeah it was
horrible and then she tried getting back
on the plane
five hours later wait what they pulled
you off for five hours yeah in Dallas
but there was another video of her
saying to get everyone off the plane why
would she try to get back on the plane
if she was a great question it's a great
question that's why she's my co-host
that was an amazing question yeah
and why would she try to get back on she
has she has blamed what she saw either
and why she did that no I know she did
no she didn't she came back on and
apologized for her actions but she never
explained exactly what she saw yes she
did what did she say she said that she
saw that she saw a shape-shift shape
yeah no that was before she said that I
know but she had taken like too much
ambien or something I don't know
something happened with something
something happened but uh that's the
lovely part of flying you know
[Music]